[Music]
yeah this is this is definitely weird
one mission to the unknown I really
meant to get this done closer when the
thing actually came out but said such as
life sometimes so Doctor Who oddities
and this one is an oddity on multiple
level levels is like oddities sectioned
we've got going on here so if you don't
know mission to the unknown was a story
from the early days of Doctor Who during
the Hartnell era and it was a one
episode story so it was about 20-25
minutes and it did not feature the main
cast of Doctor Who at all it featured a
whole new cast of characters and a
couple of basically stranded figures who
encounter the Daleks and it set some
stuff up that would pay off a couple of
stories later in I believe it was Daleks
master plan but it's kind of ancillary
and it's it's a bit of a weird thing it
was put in basically to give the main
crew a break um during the shooting
blocks and then Terry nation who wrote
the script used it a tempting to make
him of a backdoor pilot to find ways to
make money off the Daleks separate from
Doctor Who because the way that
copyright worked in the UK at the time
he had the rights to the Daleks as a
creation so if he could get them to get
traction as a thing he could take and
have them branch off from Doctor Who
which to some extent he did with some
stuff but this was one of his early sort
of attempts to kind of set that up and
get that going but that was sort of just
like what he did when he got the writing
assignment so what mission to the
unknown is now is not what it was at the
time because what it was at the time as
I said is a one episode thing but it's
one of the Lost episodes audio um was
able to be recovered no video has ever
been recovered from the
thing however currently up on the
official Doctor Who channel I'll link it
down below and I would recommend that
you watch it either I mean watch it
after I'm done talking if you want I'm
not really untalked too much in the way
of spoilers I don't think I mean there
isn't a ton to spoil as far as the thing
goes but if you want to watch it before
just pop on down and give it a look so
what's on the official Doctor Who
YouTube channel aired fifty-four years
after the original episode is a
recreation now this is not one of the
animated recreations like you've been
released on DVD and blu-ray like they
did with shot on the macro terror and
evil of the Daleks and they're going to
be doing doing with fury of the deep no
this was a live-action recreation shot
in black and white in the original
aspect ratio using effects and lighting
techniques and sound quality consistent
with what it would have been at the time
this is as pure as could be done a
recreation of what the episode was and
they that is the goal of this thing
they're not trying to improve it because
I do think to a certain extent you get
that with some of the animate
recreations a little bit like the macro
terror animated thing I saw haven't seen
all of it but I've seen clips and I
definitely notice right away like there
is no way in heck that the macro looked
as good in live-action as the animation
is making them look in terms of like the
fluidity of the movement and things like
that I'm like new so there's there's
none of that kind of reinvention and
rewriting of the history going on
instead this is an attempt to absolutely
recreate it right down to the dodgy
effects right down to the slightly off
sound effects at times all of it and
it's dang impressive and they're going
after the original script I don't think
they recycled the audio because it
synced up way too well it didn't look
like people were lip-synching to
pre-existing audio but I do not doubt
that the pacing of the audio was what
determined the pacing of this because
there are some moments
if it was being made at all with modern
Doctor Who sensibilities they would have
sped this up or altered the shot or done
that or you know not had this thing
linger there's this weird bit of dead
air and that is probably all reflected
from the audio so they know that's how
it was delivered how the lies were
delivered before that's how they're
gonna deliver them now cuz the point is
not to update the point is to try to
reinvent and recreate and bring back a
lost piece of Doctor Who history and as
that as an experiment as an exercise in
recreation as preservation it is dang
impressive like if you had told
honest-to-god if you had told me that
this was the genuine article found and
then aired I would have believed you
there really like you have to look
really really close to catch that that
maybe that's a little better than they
could have done at the time but like
across the board it's spot-on now as to
the story itself it's as I said it's an
odd little thing because it deals with
basically um two stranded men who are
trying to fix their rocket on a planet
that has Daleks on it now the Daleks are
not the only hazard there's also this
kind of plant that I am now forgetting
what it was they call it had a weird
kind of pronunciation to it but it has
these spines and if it pricks you with
it
it infects you and you will first of all
be taken over have your mind taking over
and attempt to kill other people but
then even if you get killed your body
will change into one of these plants
it's actually a pretty horrifying idea
and it's the kind of thing that the
Daleks used to do that I kind of wish
they bring back unfortunately the one
time in modern era Doctor Who that they
kind of brought back this idea of the
Daleks meddling and tinkering and and
you know having these kinds of
biological weapons or things like that
was basically Daleks in Manhattan
evolution of Daleks which is a story
that doesn't work but it it doesn't fail
because of these ideas these ideas are
good it's just unfortunately the story
where they brought them back happened to
be one that failed and I suspect this
part of the reason they don't really get
brought up anymore but this is the kind
of thing I'd really like to see brought
back because these days it really does
feel like the only threat the Daleks
pose is an armada that's gonna come and
shoot everybody um oh I suppose there
was sort of the the hollowed-out Dalek
shell thing that they that they did
introduced in asylum of the Daleks I
don't love it but that was that was
something that was in the vein of this
sort of thing so like great I can think
of two examples out of eleven series
worth of Doctor Who where the Daleks
have an mo beyond just coming in and
blowing everything up and the Daleks
used to do a lot more than that they
used to be a lot sneakier there you just
have a lot more strings to their bow a
lot more options in their arsenal and
also in this I suppose this is minorly
spoilery for the thing but again it's
not a twist story so but anyways the
Daleks are also forging an alliance with
multiple other races so that they can
better conquer the solar system now this
is the kind of thing that I wish they
could figure out a way to bring back now
before people start saying me but the
Daleks would never ally would anyone
they want to conquer everyone's like yes
they do eventually but there was a time
once upon a time where the Daleks would
ally with other races because it'll help
them conquer things now and as far as
they're concerned they'll they'll
backstab these people later and again
that's something modern Daleks now lack
they are so single-minded and so
fanatical they don't plan strategically
anymore and they used to well I suppose
they used to up until Davros got
introduced and then basically was
decided only Davros can think in that
capacity and Daleks themselves have no
imagination whatsoever which it's just a
shame the definition of what Daleks are
and what they do and what they capable
what they're capable of in the ways they
go about it has
more narrowly defined as time has gone
on so it's both interesting and a little
saddening to go back and see a time when
Daleks did more and different stuff and
I'm not sure there's too much else to
say it's a nifty little thing it's about
25 minutes of your time it is well worth
watching if you enjoy classic Doctor Who
at all and the original thing was an
oddity this recreation is an oddity but
it's a neat thing that we now have it's
pretty neat I say what do you think
about mission to the unknown whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it if you
wish to support the channel I have a
patreon which you can support and help
me eat and pay my bills but even if you
aren't up for that you can still help me
by liking subscribing and sharing this
video because that is what pleases the
Almighty algorithm because we must
worsen the algorithm lest it come forth
and exterminate us all exterminate
exterminate okay that's enough of that
there's all their stuff down there as
well there's links to my social media
the book I wrote other channels there's
now break room of the geeks which has
things like trailer reactions and fan
music videos and Let's Plays and more
stuff will be going up there over time
but get in on that now subscribe over
there too if you like what I do and
that'll wrap it up for this one folks
because you know all that stuff I
mentioned it'd be great
I don't what can I tell you what to do
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]